representa la siguiente función en el
plano coordenada y aquí nos dan un
conjunto de números que es el dominio y
otro conjunto de números que es el rango
x como está escrita la pregunta voy a
suponer que nos dicen que la función
manda el menos 8 al 4 el menos 6 al 3 el
menos 4 al 2 el menos 2 alumnos y el 0
al cero esta es una suposición que tengo
que hacer porque puede haber otras
funciones con el mismo conjunto dominio
y el mismo conjunto rango por ejemplo la
que manda el menos 8 al 3 y el menos 6
al 4 y todo lo demás lo deja igual como
aquí dice representa la siguiente
función pues están pensando en que nada
más es una así que vamos a suponer que
manda los números así vale bueno con
esto en mente déjame dibujar aquí unos
ejes para para dibujar la función aquí
en el en el plano
voy a poner primero el eje x lo voy a
poner por acá
vale entonces este de acá va a ser el
eje horizontal o bien el eje x los
valores de x son pues casi todos
negativos excepto el 0 entonces voy a
darle un poco más de prioridad a los
cuadrantes del lado izquierdo o sea los
que quedan por acá así que el el otro
eje lo voy a pintar más o menos pues
como por aquí vale entonces este de aquí
va a ser el eje y o bien el eje vertical
y ahora sí vamos a poner cada una de las
parejas de puntos que nos da esta
función en esta en esta gráfica
vamos a necesitar para x el menos 2 - 2
menos 4
4 - 6
menos seis menos ocho y nada más bueno y
el cero que está por acá y para en el
eje vamos a necesitar el 0 el 1 el 2 el
3 y el 4 muy bien entonces pasamos las
parejas voy a tomar este color rosa para
la primera entonces es menos 8 lo manda
al 4 entonces el menos ocho lo manda al
4 ahí tenemos este puntito ahora vamos
con esta de acá el menos seis lo manda
al 3 lo voy a poner en color rosa
mexicano de menos 6 lo manda del 3 muy
bien ahora el menos 4 dice que lo
mandemos al 2 un color morado en los 4
va al 2 muy bien ahora vamos con el
menos dos el menos dos queremos mandarlo
al 1
y finalmente tenemos el 0 que voy a
poner en color azul claro tenemos el 0 y
el 0 queremos mandarlo al 0 está listo
entonces ya grafica mos la función en el
plano coordenada y recuerda estamos
haciendo la suposición de que los
números se mandan así porque podría
haber otras funciones con este mismo
dominio y con este mismo rango pero como
aquí decía la siguiente función pues
hicimos esa suposición vale bueno nos
vemos hasta la próxima